[Music]
on this Friday night gazin scramble to
flee Israel orders the entire population
of Northern Gaza to move the panic in a
place already battered by air strikes
the system is on the brink of collapse
morgs are overflowing as Israel's prime
minister says he'll pound the enemy with
unprecedented Force I feel helpless for
the first time in my life I feel
helpless the pleas for Canada's
government to help those
trapped and the tunnels of Gaza could
this vast underground system be holding
Israeli hostages taken by
Hamas global national with Donna
freezen when Israel attacks gazin know
what's coming but this is expected to be
more Relentless than ever before tonight
Israel's prime minister addressed the
nation we're fighting like lions
Benjamin Netanyahu said and this is only
the beginning Israel says infantry and
tanks have already entered the Gaza
Strip and what the Army calls localized
raids and earlier today this airdrop
over Northern Gaza what looks like
gentle confetti carried a deadly warning
don't return to your homes until further
notice about 1.1 million gazin told to
get out or else ordered to move South
across Mi Gaza within the next 24 hours
the UN called that Exodus impossible and
pleaded for more time even Wars have
rules International humanitarian law and
human rights law must be respected and
upheld civilians must be protected and
also never use the shields good evening
and thanks for joining us the more than
two million people in Gaza are now
captive to Israel's next move Israel
says it's going after Hamas fighters who
staged that brutal attack on Israel and
they're searching for hostages Hamas is
holding but of the nearly 1,800 people
who have died in Gaza in 6 days many are
civilians including
children they're going to bomb all these
buildings Canadian Asia Mator fears her
and her two young children could be next
we spoke by Zoom yesterday she said they
were living minute by minute today she
sent this voice memo as they were
fleeing gaza's North we are evacuating
now we are evacuating our location now
we have no idea where are we heading
right now no idea at
all no one contacted us to go anywhere
from the Canadian government
yet she texted no electricity no WiFi
here running low on phone battery but
they have made it
South even hospitals in Gaza are being
told to evacuate which the World Health
Organization says amounts to a death
sentence for seriously ill patience
there is intense pressure on Israel to
let in humanitarian Aid and for safe
passage to get foreign civilians out we
have complete coverage tonight starting
with Jeff simple in Jerusalem
Jeff Donna Israel's military told the
United Nations that people in Northern
Gaza had until midnight Friday to
relocate to the southern half of the
Gaza Strip and Israel also said that it
intends to cut off all internet access
to Gaza starting Saturday it is of
course already Saturday morning here in
Jerusalem suggesting that widely
anticipated ground assault of Gaza could
begin at any
moment I'm preparing I'm planning when
we spoke with Aziz elute this morning
his family had packed their bags
preparing to head
south they live in northern Gaza where
these flyers were dropped by an Israeli
War Plane warning they have to leave for
their own security I'm a civilian I'm a
Jord
and I deny what
happened so why I should die me and my
family Global News has been in contact
with aiz all week as he's helped to
support our coverage from inside Gaza
his family doesn't own a vehicle so they
plan to make the hours long journey
through bombed out neighborhoods on foot
it's not like a a driving street it's
the walking and hiding Palestinians
already in southern Gaza say they've run
out of places to stay and food to eat
all these people in the hospital cannot
be
evacuated where's
Humanity we people's hearts in the world
to let this happen at this day and age
Hamas urged Palestinians to reject
Israel's evacuation order and to rise up
in violent protest after Friday
prayers Israeli police responded with
heightened security
preventing many young Muslims from
Gathering and praying at the al- AXA
mosque one of Islam's holiest sites and
a common flash
point in the West Bank Palestinian youth
clashed with the Israeli military nine
Palestinians were
killed according to officials at least
49 Palestinians have died in clashes in
the West Bank since Saturday's attack on
Israel by Hamas well what happened in
Israel actually happens in Palestine
every day and nobody talks about it this
Palestinian entrepreneur runs a tech
startup she says the West's support of
Israel's bombing campaign in Gaza sends
a painful message to Palestinians this
situation exposed the world let's say
and exposed the real View and double
standards of the world towards the
Palestinian people and how they regard
us as not as equal people but as
subhumans unfortunately what we see in
Gaza is an act of annihilation nothing
in the world could justify this a crime
does not justify another crime this
Palestinian political leader whose party
opposes Hamas points to the pro
Palestinian protests erupting Friday
across the Arab world as a sign that
this conflict risks spiraling far beyond
gaza's borders what I expect is more
vicious attacks Israel is saying that
they are preparing a ground Invasion uh
this could lead to a very huge explosion
in the north and this could mean
Regional word not just world with
Palestinians I tried to evacuate my
house late Friday night we received an
update from Aziz El calute his family
couldn't find a ride or make it out on
foot he says there's no Escape I don't
know what to do I I'm going to stay home
and all of you please forgive me and
pray for me my
family for those Palestinians trapped in
Gaza there really is no way out those
leaflets that fell in Gaza today warned
that anyone who tried to flee into
Israel risked being shot to death the
only other viable pathway out would be
Egypt through that border but the
Egyptian government has closed that door
to any potential Palestinian refugees as
a result we heard a lot of anecdotal
reports today that while many
Palestinians did move to the South many
others remain in the north refusing to
leave their homes either desperate or
defiant unable or willing to leave Donna
not a lot not a lot of options Jeff
simple in Jerusalem thanks caught in
this are about 150 people with
connections to Canada who have asked the
government for help they have no way out
right now Mercedes Stevenson is with me
Mercedes what is the Canadian government
doing to help its citizens get out of
Gaza Donna the Prime Minister has made
it clear that the government of Canada
supports Israel and its right to defend
itself but there is also deep concern
for civilians including Canadian
citizens who are trapped in Gaza with
rapidly worsening conditions no way out
and an impending extraordinary ground
assault coming in today's official
briefing in Ottawa we learned that there
may be a window opening for Canadian
citizens to leave Gaza tomorrow between
12 and 5: p.m. at the Rafa Border
Crossing into Egypt but that is far from
certain yet Foreign Affairs says that
they are not encouraging any Canadian
citizens to start moving towards the
Rafa gate at this time
the last thing we want is Canadians
getting stuck at a border um that border
uh there there are a number of security
challenges at all the borders uh into
Gaza we know that there have been um
bombs at both borders uh in in the last
week Global Affairs Canada warned that
there is still so much up in the air and
they weren't able to really give a lot
of specific answers Donna something that
they have come under Fire for when it
comes to Canadian citizens who are
currently trapped in Gaza Israeli
officials told global news that they
have been in discussions with the
Canadian government about Canadian
citizens but so far there's no
indication that Israel would consider
taking the security risk of allowing
anyone including Canadians through the
gate on their side of the border now
foreign affairs minister Melanie Jolie
was in Israel for talks today and she
was at the airport meeting with
Canadians who are boarding evacuation
flights run by the Canadian Armed Forces
headed to Athens Greece Jolie is set to
be in the region until Saturday she will
be engaging the she will be engaging a
number of nations including Greece and
Jordan and the Israeli government has
said uh through sources to us and
intelligence officials that one of the
things they are asking Western powers to
do is to Lobby those in the region to
avoid further escalation Donna all right
Mercedes Stevenson and Ottawa thanks the
American defense secretary Lloyd Austin
has gone to Israel he reiterated
American Support he said the US is
prepared to send send more military
aid the USS Gerald R Ford carrier strike
group is now in the
region led by the largest aircraft
carrier in the
world we've augmented us fighter
aircraft squadrons in the Middle
East and the US Department of Defense
stands fully ready to deploy additional
assets if
necessary you met with Israel's defense
minister and the Prime Minister over a
dozen Americans are missing the US
President Joe Biden spoke with some of
their families
today they're they're going through
Agony not knowing what the status of
their sons daughters husbands wives
children are you know it's gut-wrenching
I assured them my personal commitment to
do everything possible everything
possible to return every Mission
American to their
families a journalist with Reuters has
been killed in southern Lebanon
videographer Isam abdalah was part part
of a crew that was live streaming video
from near the Israel Lebanon
border just seconds after hearing these
gunshots the team was hit six other
journalists were injured Global News is
not airing the moment it happened
Reuters has confirmed Abdullah was
killed and is urgently seeking more
information and working with authorities
in the
region demonstrations were held in a
number of countries today supporting
Palestinians and denouncing the Israeli
bombardment of
Gaza in Yemen tens of thousands chanted
death to America death to Israel
demonstrations also took place in the
Middle East Asia and Europe Germany and
France had banned Pro Palestinian
demonstrations and several Western
countries said they stepped up security
at synagogues and Jewish
schools Gaza underground coming up why
these tunnels are a pivotal factor in
Israel's assault and the search for
hostages plus the Grim stories of
Survivor from those who live through the
Hamas
Massac when Hamas militants attacked
people in southern Israel it was
horrific civilians were murdered and
kidnapped Israel's military says more
than 1300 people were killed at least
150 others were taken hostage survivors
now are trying to piece together their
lives worried about the loved ones held
captive wondering why it was allowed to
happen and struggling with all they
witnessed Crystal ganing has been
talking to some of
them the talk at this beautiful
Mediterranean seaside resort doesn't
match the aesthetic I run and my husband
went slower and it was like it was
raining bumps last weekend Malco kety
and her husband found themselves hiding
in a shelter at their son's home on the
alumim kibutz right beside Gaza if I
would have known what was going on
outside I think I wouldn't have survived
it was like my mother survived the
Holocaust and my father also and my
sister also and they always told me that
they were they were
hiding they were hiding and no one was
looking after them no one was no one was
taking care of them no
one was nothing and uh and I had the
same
feeling there are now countless videos
showing people fleeing for their lives
from the area around the
kibuts
the festival where many other videos
were recorded took place nearby after
attacking people there The Killers moved
on to the communal living location most
of the images are so appalling we need
to blur
them for the survivors donations are
being collected roughly 400 people from
the alumim and the mithel Kuts fled with
just the clothes on their backs and
everybody is helping for now this hotel
is home in the basement there are piles
of clothes and shoes and kids items even
a playroom for little ones but it is all
a thin cover over some deep pain I've
lost countless friends and also friends
we don't know where they
are if they're dead is there in Gaza I
don't know Michael huller says people
talk and hug and they work he started
calling people to organize donations to
keep busy but he says what he really
wants is for Israel to be safe so he and
his family can go home Crystal ganing
Global News Nat
Israel still ahead the underground maze
in Gaza why it exists and why Israel
wants to smash
it Global News is on the ground as the
crisis in the Middle East unfolds just a
ton of exposing happening all around us
for the latest developments watch global
national and go to Global
[Music]
news.ca the Gaza Strip has been under a
suffocating blockade by Israel backed by
Egypt since 2007 when Hamas sees control
of Gaza Palestinians and Aid groups say
it amounts to Collective punishment it
restricts entry of goods and people and
of equipment that could be used to make
weapons and that has led to an array of
tunnels being dug Hamas uses them to
smuggle and store weapons and to move
around secretly now as Redmond Shannon
explains Israel suspects they're being
used to hide
hostages more than 1,500 people have
died in Israel's week of air strikes on
Gaza Israel's Defense Forces say they
only target Hamas militants the
buildings they use and their tunnels
think of the Gaza Strip as one layer for
the civilians and then another layer for
Hamas and what we're doing now is that
we are trying trying to get to that
second layer nicknamed the Gaza Metro by
Israel the vast network of tunnels may
look something like this they're used to
hide out or move around covertly and now
likely a place to hold some of the
hostages border tunnels to Egypt are
used to smuggle goods and weapons as
Gaza remains under blockade Hamas has
used tunnels to Israel to Stage attacks
in the past
two years ago Israel finished a
Subterranean wall designed to stop
militants from tunneling into Israel
that may explain why Saturday's attack
appeared to take place at least
primarily above ground inside Gaza the
tunnel network is estimated to be up to
30 m deep it makes a huge
complication uh this is this is a very
difficult challenge military analyst
atan Shamir says the tunnels are thought
to be most dense in Northern Gaza from
where residents have been told to leave
he believes hostages are almost
certainly held in those tunnels but that
Israeli forces won't let that distract
them from targeting militants that if
you start to take the the hostages
situation into
account uh it will it it the effect
would be total paralysis this is exactly
what what Kamas wanted Israel to to be
in this corner drones and robot
technology will allow soldiers to detect
some booby traps underground even still
the sprawling network of tunnels could
make the coming days much more deadly on
both sides and potentially for hostages
too Redman channan Global News
London next the Israeli Canadian
reservist ready to risk their lives on
the front lines against
Hamas
military service is compulsory in Israel
and right now more than 300,000
reservists with the Israeli Defense
Force are being called up just a few
months ago thousands of them had stopped
reporting for Duty protesting prime
minister Benjamin netanyahu's deeply
unpopular judicial reforms but after
that attack by Hamas on Southern Israel
they are answering the call and among
them are some Israeli Canadians Dan
Spectre has their
story when you get the call you answer
and here I am a week ago 28-year-old
oral was home in Toronto now the Israeli
Canadian whose last name we're not
airing due to safety concerns is at War
I just got back from a mission and um
I've got a little bit of time that's why
born and raised in Canada to a family of
Israelis he says he moved to Israel at
21 to join the Israeli Defense Forces
before returning to the Toronto area for
the past 2 years
after last Saturday's attack by Hamas
militants the reservist was called up to
fight I actually took um an ac130 with
um 180 other soldiers that are just like
me from can Canada and from the states
into Israel oral says he and his unit
have witnessed scenes of horror we all
have I'm they're there's not enough
there's not a way to describe it but
he's staying focused as his family back
home holds its breath they got nothing
to worry about I can take care of myself
my unit uh pretty capable guys
everything seems to be uh going our way
let's put it that way in Winnipeg this
37-year-old Israeli born pilot is
waiting for the call to join oral in his
home country it's hard enough for me to
live with myself right now knowing very
well that I tried to get called and and
and didn't manage he spent most of his
life in Israel before moving to Canada
with his family 5 years ago the IDE F
Reserve Captain fought in the 2014 Gaza
war on the first or second
day uh we lost our commanding officer
and three other soldiers to a terrorist
attack now as the war rages he's
overcome by survivors guilt I know they
know that if I'm ever called I am on the
next plane uh back to help my people
back on the front line oral has little
time to rest but his spirits are high
we're here to to do the job and to get
it done and to keep it
positive we need to get back into a
positive state of mind and uh to to not
think about the bad things just one of
countless lives being risked with every
passing moment as the violence in the
region continues Dan Spectre Global News
Montreal and that is global national for
this Friday I'm Donna freezen the world
is watching what's unfolding in Gaza and
Israel where so many innocent people
have died tonight we leave you with some
of the tributes being laid at
Palestinian and Israeli embassies thanks
for
[Music]
watching